and then Fear Factor what was the work
schedule lake for that one three days a
week but constant we did you know one
year 34 episodes I think maybe 36 time
we just [ __ ] it out
while America was eating we're [ __ ] and
[ __ ] on that plate which which they
should though cuz that show was so clean
right you for so students you set up the
game it was very amazing it was very
easy to do initially but then the second
version of it when it came back in 2000
was 11 or something like that that
version was a real problem because that
version they were ramping it up the
stunts were way more difficult way more
dangerous it would me I was freaking out
but a couple of the most like this is
getting rough like bungee jumps off a
[ __ ] helicopters in the middle of a
canyon you know launching people on
these bungee jumps there was some crazy
[ __ ] I think the eating stuff always got
to me you know people eating the bugs I
was always like like how much money did
you win on that show I can't remember
you could win well there was a couple of
shows where people won a million dollars
damn but even when you win a million
dollars you don't really win a million
dollars you win a million dollars before
the government comes in steals
everything right yeah plus is there
something for winning in on a game show
like do you have some more taken out
because it's a winning or something I
don't know
it's a lot like if someone won fifty
thousand which was a normal week they
would really take home thirty for the
government doesn't eat any animal dicks
they don't jump off any buildings and
they just steal sixteen grand from you
yeah animal I remember the animal dicks
now that was my favorite we did that in
Griffith Park served up some animal
dicks [ __ ] crazy
what a crazy show thinking back the
liability on that [ __ ] thing what's
really crazy is it all happened post
September 11 like right afterwards yeah
that's when it aired and it was a
preposterous show like from the jump and
I always thought it was going to be
canceled and it
was a giant hit was a giant huge I'd be
like immediately it was a hit I was like
this is so stupid the show is so stupid
and the reason is awesome
I got the gig was because I made fun of
it like everybody else was trying to
like be spooky like they're like you
know the fee is fear a factor for you I
came into this meeting I was high as
[ __ ] I came into this meeting and they
were they were telling me what they
wanted to do one of the casting
directors got Jeff from NBC hooked up
the meeting and he thought it would be a
good good fit for it because I was you
know I just been on NBC for Newsradio
then I came into this meeting I was like
what are you gonna do I'm like you're
gonna SiC dogs on people I'm like this
is like a I'm like this is like a bit in
an act this is like a bit of like where
it goes terribly wrong you're gonna make
people eat animal dicks need to SiC dogs
on people I'm gonna throw people off
buildings I'm like this is this is like
the Running Man idiocracy yeah it's yeah
it was before idiocracy was even a movie
I was like this is this is the most
insane idea for a television show I've
ever heard this is gonna be cancelled
immediately and I'm gonna have all this
material about remember when I used to
host Fear Factor yeah you want a hundred
and sixty [ __ ] episodes later we did
148 episodes and then we did another I
think we did six bored seven but only
six aired because one of them was the
one when they had a drink come no [ __ ]
yeah way talking about jug of [ __ ] who
made it
donkey-like from joe yeah my own to fill
up everyone stein are you [ __ ]
kidding me donkey come and now it's a
cattle prod up a donkey's [ __ ] yeah
and they would come like god they zap um
zap them in the Old Testament but ckets
yeah and they played horseshoes so they
played horseshoes and you can never win
even if you made like a ringer and you
like made that you would have to drink
one ounce but if you [ __ ] up you were
drinking like 10 11 12 ounces these are
jugs judge
yeah so what happened was I remember
yeah what happened was the TMZ folks got
a whole [ __ ] they got ahold of the
pictures of these people drinking come
early and then it became this giant fear
that like people like what like what
there's no way this is real like this is
a joke right
no it turns out they really did make
them drink calm he just choked it down
his brother is right next to his twin
brother helping him choke down come how
much money and not enough 34 grand
whatever they went inside they want a
billion dollars if Warren Buffett sucks
their dick and then look immediately you
get to throw up and these poor girls are
here's this interesting girls chose to
come over the urine I mean yeah we're
[ __ ] drinkers you learn to do this [ __ ]
when you're 15 man long she's been
training her whole life for this moment
mm-hmm oh so hard so hard to imagine
that that was a real show I know looking
back now yeah but at the time everybody
watched this every bit was normal well
this was the one that killed it yeah
that episode killed that and now
Ludacris took it over Luda damn
but Ludacris is doing like a bolt like
well is it fear factor if you leave your
house without your phone like right like
what are the what do they do they don't
do is still on they're doing season two
now there's definitely not a biology
page I figured something would be
uploaded Risa
maybe what's ahead maybe I don't know
Luda
they came to me though before this I'm
like [ __ ] there's not enough money you
don't have enough money to go you
wouldn't ever host it again oh really
over it's over I did it yeah you didn't
done that [ __ ] yeah I'm so not
interested well but I'm glad I did do it
it was it was great for the time I mean
that was the thing and it's good it was
good because it was money that's what it
was good for it was good because I
didn't have to worry about money and
then when you have to worry about money
like you don't worry about your choices
comedic ly like I didn't worry like oh
if I say something then they're gonna
cancel me or fire me from the show and
then I can't do it anymore
if I didn't that wasn't that wasn't my
concern at all my concern was like okay
now I have enough money so I don't have
to worry about not having money and I
already make money doing stand-up so now
I put some money away so now you're free
now I could do whatever yeah you're
doing create whatever the [ __ ] you want
just just free to do stand-up and free
to do with however I've won and with no
worries about Tonight Show sets or any
of that [ __ ] nonsense
yeah so wait so that when you were doing
excuse me Fear Factor was there a thing
where you couldn't kind of do your
stand-up the way you wanted to before
that yeah and there was some concern
with their you know they had talked to
me once about drugs I talk too much
about drugs like like one of the
producers pull me aside and it's like
you know you're doing these interviews
you're talking about like these these
are illegal drugs I go yeah you should
do them do DMT it's good for you